okay burn all the fuel and h2o
kick off in less than 15 quick rundown
warzone rated cube fanatics 88 players
17:51 average rating time handicapped
criteria none ending in 30 minutes let's
go here we go efore for the win
get over here ticker the ticker the cube
fanatic clock keeper right there alright
this is d5 can be played now I'll just
back my light square Bishop up and get
play on the a file if it's captured it's
f4 there oh there might be um maybe not
just to stop a knight there with tempo
get my king right here oh oh oh I'm in
trouble
Knight to g5 would have been a killer I
couldn't take it coz of Queen h4 mate
can you believe it you should believe it
that's what was gonna happen oh that was
scary you get rid of that what am i
doing
let's do this okay it's okay it's coming
together it's coming together let's go
Queen h6 you know you want to go there
Bishop needs to go oh this is TKO back
to tournament - somebody has three
somebody has two games in I had a quick
designer that would have been scary
Knight g4 would have been very scary oh
let's go I have 696 are they gonna grab
the pawn and give me the center they
might grab the pawn still okay now it's
not free anymore it's not a free pawn
take now for my bishop move bit Queen to
d6 Queen d6 time coming up rook here
this file is gonna open up isn't it it
is here we go
a bunch of exchanges chop chop chop
chop back up Queen d6 coming up Queen d6
sneaky sneaky oh oh let's go get rid of
that night
get out of there night why'd I do that I
want to stay on this dial get rid of the
night Knight g5 I'll be very scared be
very scared check and then mate h2 back
to tournament eight six three no
surprise Kappa rod up there he's gonna
hit 300 points wait you see oh man it's
the 300 Club okay let's go the center's
not being challenged right here they're
going with them not sure what you call
it like a small pawn Center here we go
kick the bishop away Bishop d3 f5
fishing-pole Castle Castle castle come
over here not you want to play over here
the King is fleeing fearing the fishing
pole he's fearing the fishing pole
that's why he's going this direction f5
is in chop right here I'm getting ready
to hit this pond maintenance or to
something close to it no no no I should
take that pawn with check queen block no
let's come back here and okay I got the
C file stop that knife from coming here
I can't castle that's sad
let's go here oh I have this covered I
have it covered by the queenie if i play
here no i could play here i have this
check as a possibility now i don't like
taking that rook I would much rather do
this actually I let me take the rook I
like I lied I do want to do that hit the
Queen get my other night doing something
he wants to play too
actually let me do this get rid of that
night
and then get the rook my clean active
that pond is in a pen my night on g3 is
doing nothing
let's get doing something you got the
Queenie oh they're gonna get the Queen
back if I did that oh that was slick
right there I want to get this point can
I get that
Bishop spent eight seconds I don't have
any time
where did my time go hmm what's
happening here my Queens my King's gonna
get checked oh no it's getting checked
like crazy no run away oh it's a making
one threat do I have me I have me or
something close
I just want to trade trade trade trade
trade trade trade check how much time
okay move there's gonna be a check
thrown in or something I want to get out
of stalemate huh oh man I got nervous
right there cuz I always I didn't have a
good mouse um all right I didn't have a
good uh pre move register in there man I
have a terrible mouse I really do this
thing is crap you have no idea ah okay
I'm playing with the handicapped mouse
right here it's not fun let's go each
part do your job here let's go oh the
night's gonna come to f5 my nights gonna
go to f8 though no it's not okay double
up the box the night out if I recapture
like that I might want to do like seif
yeah I definitely know I'm not definite
or let's just do this sack the sack time
chop push up on and then take a pint
with the check I just want to open it up
oh okay I want to take care with check
or something no it's defended okay
Bishop d6 soon real soon dark squares
dark squares rook here I have a time
edge time edge they must be scared I'm
getting material that's check I got the
bishop and I
his pen the queen is gonna be hit pawn
push let's back up hang on pawn push
next rope right here he wasn't doing
anything on d1 d8 pawn push pawn push
again the rook is gonna get killed
let's take this knight first so it can't
block now it's pinned look out it's
pinned the rook is pinned it's powerless
that's it that's TKO back to tournament
2038 no 38 23 22 guys ahead ah let's go
here
Scandinavian so this is Transpo oh I
should just take in that pond okay I
have our space on this side of the board
the bishops gonna come out let's get rid
of it it's really strong I want to get
an f5 f5 probably right now before it's
too late
g6 might stop it all together and now
get castled and target f7 f7 coming up
Knight g5 stuff Knight g5 or not let's
do this stop the knight from coming out
f6 coming up maybe this I guess they're
gonna go Queen side and let me target
this pawn I'm gonna move my knight where
do I want to go up my knight right here
and then to this square take that the
knight it's got to be a very awkward pin
so now I'm gonna attack it now there's
this knight move after there's capture
and the default pans up except I
actually know that that can't happen
I was thinking then I could take the
pawn but not so fast I end up getting
that at the end of it so there's still a
pin going on here and let me call over
here I want my Queen to get to a5 Queen
wants to get to a5 she's not getting
there oh the night's gonna take this
pawn just push here actually I'll open
it up on this side pawn push again I
want to keep my clean around pawn push
pawn push capture and then Queen to a6
they wouldn't really take that would
they mate threat coming up this is
Meghan 2
unavoidable actually no matin one King
has to go back back to tournament 3052
there's got to be with quick resign errs
there's no 52 I'm still having
flashbacks when we played last against
the guy that's in top
I dropped a rook for a pawn I was up a
pond I dropped a rook okay settle down
here settle down
is this gonna open up come on let's go
over here a six b5 I said have done B
six like that he had a baby step it now
I could have gotten to b5 of one shot
now push capture I want the D file the
knight is running out of squares isn't
it break this open we capture with my
queen or not I don't know what I want to
do let me do this first take my night I
take their nighttime on their queen oh I
should take here actually okay this is
working out this is good this is the
right idea um otherwise I get chased
around with that Bishop push or
something let's get rid of this night
maybe I should you know just back up my
light square bishop let's go get on this
light square get on the light squares I
want to get rid that night get rid of
the night real soon light squares all
right here light squares chase the Queen
away deflection
oh I wake up my dark squares get oh
there it is oh wait I had me or no I
didn't know I didn't know I didn't now I
want to deflect the Queen away rook
right here coming up oh this is a killer
that's got to be a killer there's no
good solution is there no good solution
that's me back to Jeremy 4268 4200
there's 19 minutes and change I think in
order to catch that guy I'm gonna end up
needing to be paired up against him and
that's I'm not too realistic is it it's
rare that that would happen but maybe
that's my only chance to go to go up 20
and then
am i doing am i doing here
I don't want to drop that pun and let's
do this actually bump might get my
bishop back I'm gonna stop Knight there
do not want to deal with that oh man
okay things are crumbling over here how
much time is left I don't have very much
time there could have been Bishop c5 and
I would have been on castled so let me
get on my Knight to d6 knight on d6
oh and it gets there with tempo I'm on
the Queen and the d6 check oh they
missed it I got everything resigned
resign resign resign you could take that
pawn just take this open it up another
Bishop oh I should play Bishop there I'm
on the knight now give a check okay this
is this is leading to me just move back
to tournament that was kind of quick
8650 six nine games in come on don't
resigned to that guy resigned to me
quick resigned a quick resigned
where are they I need some help I'm
coming for help
where are the resign errs push them
around here here we go f5 I'm preparing
for this f4 advance I get that in stop
Knight g5 and okay actually I'm gonna do
this I could drop my LightSquared Bishop
my king might want to run in this
direction actually oh okay I'm gonna do
that
oh I thought going in the other
direction was best my King has a nice
home over here or here even Queen to h5
that's very nice very nice so how do I
deal with that the Queen has to leave
before I can do anything exciting so get
out of there Queen you got to go pawn
push coming up get out of there Queen
let's go pints and now King you need to
take a hike
take a hike King run
over in this direction where it's safe
you're gonna have fun over here right
over here is where you want to be let's
open it up their King is in trouble
right oh oh oh this is problem problem
territory we're tied up timewise let's
do that opposite the Queen pawn push
I'll back my Bishop up no let's do this
get on this diagonal now their rooks are
dead mate threat very difficult to me
gone back to tournament 106 10 games in
that's too difficult me and what's going
on like I have everybody intimidated
they just see his name and they resign
as soon as the game starts how do you
have 10 games in so let me do some
research has there been quick resign
Erza gainst that guy queen is dead she's
cooked a cooked Queen resignation
come on the Queen's dead ah to play nun
oh they're giving me the house here this
is um the kitchen sink variation right
here
come on Knight look for the quick wins
Queen f4f 7mate threat kill the knight
f7 is still on maybe uh I should have
played Knight g4 instead of that dark
squares dark squares matin - threat me
to the row actually it's unavoidable
back to tournament 104 94 oh they
actually slipped up 1110 there was a
slip-up that could be a big game that
could be a really really big game if it
happens that could be for all the
marbles for all the confetti here we go
it's being launched it's being launched
I didn't mean to do that I meant to do H
5 H 5 you seen it before k-- right here
Queen c2 Queen C to do that it's a very
good move 94
I took what the wrong night let's get
back here night there might be Bishop f4
I'm not gonna do it get to D for time
actually I want to try it again
I want try it again let's get back there
night oh there oh it's a good thing I've
discovered I'm a dead man
am i dead man I got a guard my night I
should take this if the night goes here
I chop and then chop again the night's
gonna land a killer fork though
somewhere okay I think there's still
something here give a check queenside
castle smash through at this point pawn
push so my light square bishop can see
he wants to be able to see let's do this
Dodger Knight check and get out of there
night okay there's gonna be another
check just take that night right they
don't have any time
checkmate main to threat still a main to
threats something close got the Queen at
least back determined to down on time
124 110 12 games in they have I have ten
games in oh I keep looking to see if I'm
paired up with the top dog is it gonna
happen it could happen
oh it's a big game if it comes up to
that lets do or die Oh be very prepared
let's go let's go a five get the F part
Oh
I'm just up I'm just out material what's
happening go over here I'm on b7 I get
kicked I'm gonna go over here now let me
make sure this pawn is dead I'm guarding
this and let me do what next trade
Knights get and get on this pawn right
here my queen wants to be on g3 oh this
is a killer I'm up a lot of material
probably gonna be up to clean are they
gonna recapture I'm on the clean I got
the Queen come on I have plenty of time
right I'm gonna guard that I could get
here no matter what
right here mate threat coming up meeting
something making something making
something get the rookie yes back to
tournament what we got 1:30 I'm in the
lead oh I think you dropped back I think
there was another lives
get ready 12 minutes and change
I mean first I could smell the confetti
I could smell the confetti top three
confetti land if you're new to the
stream you know it's the confetti that
everybody's after okay get prepared be
very prepared right here okay I could
take this pond it's free there's no
Perpetual on the Queen is there mm-hmm
maybe get over here discoveries
discovery land I want to get this move
in no no no no no oh man okay well what
do you do mmm
Castle no let's do this watch f7 hang on
hang on oh this is very scary oh this is
very scary I've got to do it though I
guess
oh how sneaky are they being here
they're being very sneaky oh I dropped
that okay I gotta get this get the Queen
get the Queen get the Queen there's
gonna be a pawn push it's got to be a
pawn push just back up you know I didn't
want to do this can I get this in break
down this structure I should have done
that or something Oh let me get this
pond there's no there's no pen just yeah
I get this pond I'm hitting everything
I'm hitting everything soon I got the
rook I should have taken it with my
queen oh this is there mate oh there's
two who made against my clean my heart
just skipped a beat that's what that
little grunt was right
that was my heart skipping a beat defend
everything over here be very safe please
just be safe kill the bishop kill that
Bishop get rid of it okay let's be safe
here go over here take the pawn give a
check I got the Queen run pawn your past
cut the King off run not too fast run
let's gamble this guy up get behind here
guard a rookie put your Pawnee go for a
touchdown and go quick quick quick quick
quick let's go go quicker check check
okay they resigned back to term at 150
150 140 for nine minutes and change oh
oh now I don't want to be paired up with
the top guy let me just win in this way
you just stay behind you just stay
behind okay let's go all right double
pawns
no okay let's do this just go somewhere
what am i floundering here
stop that Bishop from pinning my knight
no pins allowed no pins allowed I'm on
eight seven are they gonna miss it
they're not gonna miss it what is my
knight doing he's stupid stupid night he
wants to get to f5 though oh man I want
to get over here
the excitement is over here now the
bishops cooked its a cooked bishop right
okay oh no it's not oh wait wait a
second hang on hang on we're gonna have
a Queen trade be prepared
let's get over here move Knight so I
could get the beep on I shouldn't back
up because I'm gonna pin this Bishop is
a killer I gotta go kini h2 and then
back the bishop up and that's what I
have planned right here I have a time
edge to the Queen kaput okay now I could
back up and what is my queen doing she
is not doing anything exciting here my
knight wants to go where oh man right
here right here
that was the weakness that was left
with the last move less than 10 seconds
team black running out of fuel oh I got
the Queen no I don't now for free at
least I'm gonna get kicked around what
do I got the bishop get that rook give a
check hit this there's a skewer anything
okay back to Terminal one 7000 believe I
do want to be paired up let's go it's my
only chance is it we're not getting
paired up are we gonna get paired up oh
it's close it's a close one
okay Queen side fiend keto its Queen c7
I'm on f4 how do you defend it you
weaken your light squares kick that
queen around pawn push pawn push again
okay let's go home he's not too good for
his home Knight to f5 h4 secured by
Knights position I'm on the clean defend
like this skewer time move the knight
push the night away and then get bishop
in not too late for that
let's do this shut down that bishop
pressure on these guys my bishop mb7
queenside castle I have this covered
queenside castle might want to just sack
on this square let's open it up over
here at first get a pawn push in my
knight once you get to f5 no I got this
oh it's grumbling for because I got the
Queen resignation it's it's crumbling
right now domino effect I have a time
edge back to tournament that was fairly
quick 204 190 16 games Oh
six minutes to change Benko gamma tier
here we go we played in that a 5 minute
one alright and this okay
and now uh-oh I think that might have
been a mouse slip pawn push I might want
to do its trade get rid of their
LightSquared bishop now I want to keep
the Queen's on the board I think I have
an advantage with the Queen's on the
board pawn push and then what I think
they're in trouble I get c5 in
I got a pin
the queen is pinned this is gonna be
resignation I think no resignation
should there be resignation no oh look
at the pressure look at the pressure
I'll be very scared the lights okay
these guys come off my knight wants to
get to c6 with tempo no forks
I got a rook with check now maybe
resignation with check check looking for
me really soon
check get the rooks off they don't have
any time get h7 if the rooks are
exchanged okay back determine 244 you
beat that geez that is ridiculous he was
gonna get 300 I was kind of joking
around that's like a very high number to
be getting in these tournaments ah B 5 B
4 and then expand on the queenside is
the plan white should be trying to get
an f4 in this position oh they could
actually take there I can't recapture
cuz my Brooks unprotected since I played
b5 he's hanging ok now I actually have
it protected let's come back watch over
this pawn and now expand with f5
eventually I think I want to just get
Bishop B 7 inch first in my rook to
right now let's do this right here I
guess
f5 he's got to go watch over this pawn
and actually my rook wants to get back
home go home no let's watch over this
it's being hit now they left the dog you
know that's a problem hit the Queen get
on this diagonal oh wait wait wait wait
no it's okay it's okay it's okay
I can't I can't push right there it was
in a pin I want to get this in I got to
chase that rook away oh they're doing
good right there
okay let's come over here it's safer
rook right here I want to take that pawn
double up as well they're gonna defend
Bishop Bishop g2 it's the only defence
Bishop g2 okay I got this
coming up the rookie is kind of dead to
the game check over here looking for
mates pins I get that rook at the very
least pawn push the rook is trapped
there's no time no time left just burn
their time do anything at this point
okay back determined to 3274 four games
more in there that's crazy
Wow okay queenside castle and okay let's
tell that in in between there my pond is
hungrier he's a hunger your power and I
think or is he I didn't just win
material there did I look up and over
catch them in a primo primo primo
premiums just fog push okay they have a
covered yupper okay let's go rookie over
here go like this and then okay you know
oh that ponds gonna push they're being
sneaky being sneaky
I'm pushing the sand let's just come
here they're in a pin at least and I
have pressure on this okay this is a
good spot dark squares what get my darks
for a bishop doing something oh I
thought it was gonna be that's dumb
okay time win I need time burners time
burners where are you where are the time
burners when you need them
here we go sack back pom push open it up
open it up hit that rook it's very scary
I shouldn't have done that that's very
weakening let's capture this and then go
over here and then right here here grab
the knight get to this square somehow
let's do this defend everything
am I getting you mated how much time
then have any time right I can't move my
rook now cannot move the rook oh I got
the Queen let's go to the corner oh why
did I do that just do anything just move
they don't have any time just move time
burners 252 people are people just do
this to see my reaction
that's crazy six more games he's gonna
have 30 games in it's a 30 minute
tournament Wow
1 minute left ah there's no catch in
that guy there had to have been quick
reciters there's absolutely no way no
way I'm not believing it no way I say no
way to that can i I'm chase that night
away D 6 and then e 5 D 685 is the plan
the night needs support right now the
rook needs to go D rip d1 are they just
gonna let the clock burn this is how
it's gonna end
and okay
I think it's saved actually cuz I didn't
like a night and I'm gonna try this
anyhow the night has to go here and
there has to be an in-between move
Bishop takes Bishop if the King okay I'm
actually just winning material now
alright I'm gonna defend the night and
it's in a pin oh there's a check oh
there goes the car no I'm defended
nevermind
false alarm on that one second
Oh second place confetti ah what can you
do what can you do what can you do man
I'm doing the best I can 3:30 24 games
what good games ah man I'm anxious to go
and sniff out what this story was here
let's see what's going on here game
history I'm tracking this down I'll get
into the root of it 24 games look at
this two moves zero moves one move zero
moves one two three four
oh jeez look at that look at that man or
the hell resigns resign resign resign or
not yeah resign resign resign resign and
this one right here was only uh like his
eighth mover can it be resign who's
resigning you can't be resigning
was the other guy
hey you can't be resigning either no
more resigning where else
scorpion no more resigning you could win
play on Nonna fry them if you have to
Nonna fried if you have to I already
went to this one 334 250 203 199 that
was a good one
one night these are high - nice
Jonathan cm tota robic good tournament
okay